[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans ce nouveau
7,8 le débat la france est candidate
pour accueillir l'exposition universelle
de 2025 tout comme le japon le bureau
international des expositions a jusqu'en
2019 pour trancher entre les deux pays
en france le projet est d'organiser
cette manifestation géante sur
différents sites du grand paris et le
campus de paris saclay s'est porté
candidat pour accueillir le village
global de l'exposition quels sont les
atouts de cette candidature quelles
retombées attendues et une autre
question s'impose quel est le rôle des
expositions universelles aujourd'hui
alors que de nombreuses autres
manifestations internationales existent
avec nous ce soir pour en discuter
david ross vous êtes maire d'orsay gens
chargés selon vous êtes professeur
d'histoire contemporaine à lui fait est
ce qu et raphaël vidot wellington vous
êtes artiste chercheur et prospectiviste
et vous êtes l'auteur de ce livre
paris ars universalis scénario fiction
du futur grand paris
je me tourne d'abord vers vous jean
charles ghislain peut-on dire que les
expositions universelles suscite un peu
moins d'enthousiasmé que celle qu'on
garde en mémoire du début du 20e siècle
si on regarde les chiffres par exemple
de fréquentation des expositions oui on
peut le dire la dernière en date que
celle de milan a tiré 22 millions de
de visiteurs quand on compare à
l'exposition universelle de paris par
exemple de 1915 en avaient attiré le
double voilà bon après le sait de
shanghai en 2010 on avait attiré 73
millions donc sans accumuler les
chiffres ces variables d'une d'une
exposition à une autre mais il peut et
on peut dire oui qu'aujourd'hui à moins
enthousiaste que nous font les
expositions universelles
parce que leur signification n'est pas
la même et le rôle qu'elle joue dans la
transmission de l'information ne se fait
pas dans le même contexte il ya beaucoup
d'autres canaux aujourd'hui pour
s'informer que ce qui existait dans
l'est lors des premières expositions
universelles on peut penser que oui à
moindre engouement pour ces événements
david ross vous décourage pour vous
porter la candidature donc de paris
saclay qu'est ce que vous attendez pour
votre territoire
pas d'avancée une candidature qui
portait par le département de l'essonne
l'agglomération paris saclay et donc les
deux villes
or ces gif sur yvette on attend surtout
de faire gagner la france puisque vous
l'avez dit dans votre introduction c'est
le japon qui sera en face de la france
donc la france doit choisir sa
candidature d'ici l'été
la décision du bureau international à la
fin de l'année prochaine et donc on
espère surtout d'abord faire gagner la
france
et puis mettre en phase peut-être qu'on
en reparlera la thématique de cette
exposition qui est portée par la france
savoir la connaissance à partager la
planète à protéger et ce qui est en
train de se développer sur ce territoire
là de paris saclay de ce cluster
scientifique et de l'opération d'intérêt
national qui couvrent à la fois le
département de l'essonne et celui des
yvelines raphaël vidot wellington c'est
vrai vous le dites dans votre livre les
esprits universelle c'est un petit peu
aussi pour les villes une façon de se
réinventer de se reconstruire de se
donner une nouvelle identité
oui donc moi j'ai eu l'occasion avant
d'écrire ce livre sur le grand paris qui
résulte d'un peu tout un projet de
recherche que je mène depuis plusieurs
années à la sorbonne
j'ai aussi eu l'occasion de travailler
avec des urbanistes chinois de tong
university sur l'expo universelle de
shanghai dont j'ai eu plusieurs
expériences
en effet les expos universelles on peut
voir ça comme simplement un méga
événement en fait je trouve que c'est
plutôt
mon analyse c'est plutôt que c'est une
espèce d'occasions de théâtraliser une
mutation urbaine qui de toutes les
façons est nécessaire et d'une certaine
manière si cette pensée de cette manière
là là ça devient vraiment intéressant
parce que ça mais en la ville en
mouvement et du coup l'accès universel
est intéressant s'il s'inscrit dans une
stratégie de fond du territoire c'est
pas simplement un event avec un coup
médiatique un effet de communication
ça c'est la dimension superficielle
finalement le public a tendance à ne
voir que ça parce qu'on oublie de
restaurer voilà c'est dit et ce
caractère transformationnel du
territoire sur une période parfois assez
longue
une expo ça se prépare une dizaine
d'années en avance et donc voilà ce qui
m'intéressait c'était de en travaillant
sur le grand paris il se trouve que les
pouvoirs publics ont une démarche pour
une part un peu technostructure une
technostructure elle avec la mobilité
gouvernance mais tout ça ça fait pas le
grand paris est donc dans mon scénario
fiction
j'utilise en fait l'hypothèse d'une expo
universelle pour mettre en mouvement
toute la région ile de france et faire
ce grand paris le grand paris devenant
une expo universelle permanente donc ces
mêmes aussi une manière de régler le
caractère éphémère des expos
universelles non pas juste après sur la
praye exposition très important david
ross vous avez pensez vous à paris
saclay sur le long terme pour cette
candidature ah bah tout à fait je suis
en phase avec ce qui vient d'être dit
puisque le une fois encore le thème
c'est la planète à protéger le public
exemple on protéger la planète c'est que
lorsqu'on construit des bâtiments qui
ont une certaine fonction c'est que ce
soit pas juste pour trois mois ou six
mois mais bien que ce soit pensée dans
la durée et donc c'est bien tout
l'intérêt de notre candidature c'est que
on n'a pas besoin de cette candidature
pour faire vivre notre territoire
en revanche ce qui va être développé sur
notre territoire et étant en phase avec
ce que l'on souhaitait développer et le
avec la problématique de cette
exposition il ya une rencontre de fait
qui fait que ça justifie pleinement
notre candidature rappelons le vous êtes
un des principaux hubs kloster
académique technologique opérées parmi
les 10 novembre en monster dans le monde
effectivement scientifique de votre
légitimité pour cette candidature sur la
partie scientifique mais aussi sur tout
ce que l'on souhaite développer en
termes d'ouverture à l'international
puisque c'est aussi le but de ce cluster
et comme l'exposition peut-être que si
l'on dira davantage mais l'objectif là à
l'époque c'était un peu d'imposer le
rôle de la france là c'est vraiment de
partager et c'est vraiment cet état
d'esprit là en tout cas qui alimente
tout notre territoire
j'ai rechargé selon justement sur la
nature la fonction de ses expositions
aujourd'hui quelle est elle elle est de
proposer de thé réflexion globale sur
des enjeux voilà environnementaux
urbanistique technologique etc
ce qui n'a pas toujours été le cas
puisque historiquement vous le l'évoqué
à l'instant elle avait aussi un rôle
politique voire jeu politique d'affirmer
un régime un pays
c'était le cadet des premières
expositions universelles au 19e siècle
c'était je pense pour la france la
première année en 1855 on est quelques
années seulement après après la
proclamation du second empire et il
s'agit évidemment pour napoléon iii de
d'afficher les fastes du régime et ce
sera le cas pour la deuxième en 1867
toujours organisée par par le second
empire à la troisième république reprend
cette idée en 1878 il s'agit de montrer
le redressement de la france
après les désastres de la guerre de 70
71 de la commune en 1889
évidemment c'est le centenaire de la
révolution française l'en croire le la
dimension politique est importante et on
le trouve ailleurs qu'en france vous
avez l'exposition de philadelphie aux
états unis en 1876 qui est aussi
l'exposition du centenaire de la
déclaration d'indépendance en ce sens
politique de la tour eiffel et 1889 la
tour eiffel ce sens politique l'a
peut-être c'est peut-être atténuer
aujourd'hui même si évidemment les
expressions reste des vitrines essentiel
pour les pays qui les qui les organisent
est-ce qu'on raisonne pas plus
aujourd'hui en termes de métropole
plutôt qu'en terme de nation raphaël
vidot harrington a aujourd'hui ccc
grands centres urbains qui travaillent
leur rayonnement finalement plus que les
pays
c'est un petit peu les deux disons que
dans ces eaux là on est dans une des
questions qui touchent aux qu'on appelle
le soft pas avoir vraiment comment les
nations se font ce feu se faisait la
concurrence est maintenant en effet seul
le lait la guerre la compétition entre
les territoires se joue beaucoup plus
elles celle de métropole y compris à
l'intérieur des pays
parce que ça correspond à des échelles
ou aussi des citoyens se sont beaucoup
plus attachés à leur ville qu'à leur
pays
il ya un ancrage local qui se fait
beaucoup plus à l'échelle de la
métropole
et puis les métropoles sont peut-être
plus agile à mettre en mouvement que les
états donc en effet la concurrence entre
les métropoles est très très vives dont
paris traditionnellement fait la maman
paris et londres c'est vraiment le voilà
le bras de fer est elle pour l'analyser
expo universelle
c'était déjà londres est la première à
accueillir expression donc mon bouquin
je fais tout un chapitre sur le pavillon
anglais justement qui vit un peu clore
le récit donc lui ces stratégies de soft
power et donc que le talent des
métropoles mais il ya aussi tout à face
de gagner là conclut le concours pour
avoir le droit d'accueillir et ça c'est
vraiment une sacrée bataille d'influencé
internationale a mené au sein du bureau
international des expositions qui
l'un des rares organes à avoir des
représentants de plus de 180 pays c'est
à dire qu'il ya les nations unies
l'unesco
et puis ensuite c'est le comité
international olympique a également
passé les expulsions voilà où il ya tous
les pays de la planète qui s'entend avec
des représentants qui sont des
ambassadeurs et des candidatures qui
sont portées directement par les
présidents donc on oublie même ce levier
de soft power qui est déterminant de
toute la phase amont et le moi je fais
un chapitre où vit sur cette volée comme
sa stratégie que savent pas voire
internationale david ross justement
alors vous vous êtes en compétition avec
marne-la-vallée pardon avec gonesse la
vallée de l'ourcq
qu'est ce que justement par rapport à ce
que vient de dire a fait le boulot into
qu'est ce que ça veut dire pour vous
vous sentez vraiment
concerné en tant que territoire et pas
en tant que pays alors on se sent
concernée en tant que territoire pour le
pays et comme on a eu l'occasion de le
dire parce qu'on a fait une soirée un
peu vainement ciel avec tous les acteurs
qui nous soutiennent moi j'ai eu
l'occasion de dire que nous allons
gagner
pas uniquement parce que nous sommes les
plus forts si nous sommes le plus fort
mais parce que nous sommes les plus
forts pour la france voilà qu'on estime
que par rapport à osaka par rapport au
thème que j'évoquais tout à l'heure et
aussi par rapport à la manière dont on
souhaite repenser la suite de
l'exposition on sera en bonne situation
de faire gagner la france que ça a été
dit c'est un pays une voix et donc qu'il
faut regarder ce qu'on va mettre sur la
table par rapport à ceux un pays une
voix ou là il faut être non pas entre
guillemets ostentatoire et écraser tout
le monde mais séduire donc c'est notre
manière de voilà de rayonner ses rayonné
par la séduction par la conviction et
donc on estime qu'on a un certain nombre
d'atouts qu'on a développés à cette
soirée qui sont uniques par rapport aux
trois autres candidatures qui entraîne
des crêtes très bonnes candidatures très
nombreux sites et non 3 3 a tous les
atouts qu'on retrouve dans les autres
candidatures c'est à l'accès aux
transports puisqu'on à l'aéroport d'orly
notre candidature à dire oui j'ai roissy
mais ce qui est intéressant c'est de
voir quels sont les pays qui arrivent à
orly justement par rapport au vote
vous voyez que par rapport à ce que
l'idée c'est aussi d'attirer pour la
suite vous verrez des collaborations
dans la durée avec ces pays donc les
transports au relie la gare de massy qui
permet est ce que c'est vous avez parlé
du village central
ensuite l'idée c'est de rayonner sur un
certain nombre de villes françaises et
donc massy à une distribution à peu près
entre 1h30 et 2h30 dans un grand nombre
de métropoles françaises
et puis les accès à 6 à 10 518 donc tous
les accès routiers et puis surtout donc
l'idée enfin l'atout majeur pour nous
c'est effectivement comme je les dis on
avait l'idée d'un cluster qu'on
construit pour les 15 à 20 prochaines
années
il se trouve qu'on avait donc que 65
hectares qui étaient pas encore décidé
dans la manière dont on allait là ménagé
et l'idée c'est de la ménager à la fois
pour l'exposition universelle mais aussi
pour la suite de l'exposition
universelle
et donc pour l'étape 2 de ce qu'on
voulait faire sur le guen qui était pas
prêt et donc de coordonner tout ça et
l'idée c'est en fait que les bâtiments
lorsque c'est que chaque pays construit
son bâtiment alors première idée c'est
d'éviter la surenchère de c'est le pays
le plus important quel bâtiment plus
gros donc il ya tout en rappelant lancé
un ensemble de pavillons de chaque pays
silva d'après il ya là il ya une idée
qui est porté d'ailleurs par jean
christophe fromantin qui est de mettre
une géode au milieu qui permet de faire
une visite virtuelle de tous les pays ce
qui fait que chaque pays déjà peut faire
passer incitons de messages par les
nouvelles technologies donc ça c'est
quelque chose d'intéressant
il restera les pavillons et l'idée qu'on
a c'est que ces pavillons qui vont être
financés par les états membres puissent
ensuite être convertis en priorité pour
ces pays là avec deux deux idées
l'accueil des étudiants il ya énormément
de collaboration de recherche et
d'études avec un grand nombre de pays
notamment francophones d'afrique et donc
je rappelle un pays une voix donc de les
accueillir et de favoriser en tout cas
lors leur possibilité de s'implanter de
vivre sur le campus universitaire de
demain et de la même façon de garder des
locaux pour des start up pour tout le
parcours de création d'entreprise que
l'on souhaite développer sur le domaine
du développement durable et là aussi
d'avoir des partenariats entre les
grands groupes français des start up
française et les start-up de ces pays
émergents
j'ai rechargé sauce est tout un
programme on est loin quand même des
anciens exposition universelle là on
s'inscrit vraiment avec une vision
économique de développement du
territoire
c'est beaucoup plus complexe qu'avant
oui le les premières expositions
universelles était peut-être moins dans
la prospective pour le coup free dont
ménagement urbain sur le long terme même
si évidemment il y a qu'à se balader
dans paris sur les bords de seine pour
retrouver les trois expositions
universelles vous parliez de la tour
eiffel c'est le meilleur exemple le
palais de son cadet rookie d'en face le
palais tokyo tout ça ce sont des restes
des expositions universelles
même si elle n'était pas prêt conçu au
départ forcément pour rester dans la
pérennité
le pai trocadéro et pour le construire a
fallu abattre le précédent pavie pallec
été construits là pour l'exposition
précédente donc ça ne s'inscrit pas
pardon forcément dans la durée sur les
enjeux de développement
il était peut-être plus plus idéologique
dans les premières expositions dans la
mesure où il y avait une exaltation
quand même du progrès économique et
technique dansé dansé expositions qui
était vraiment des temples parce que ce
sont des vitrines technologiques
cette vitrine industrielle à l'époque
mais c'est le salaire de de la
révolution industrielle de
l'industrialisation du développement des
chemins de fer de la métallurgie et
chaque pays justement vient montrer
là les progrès qu'il a pu accomplir
chaque exposition d'ailleurs est en
quelque sorte une comparaison avec la
précédente pour montrer que ça n'arrête
pas de progresser
c'est très 19e comme idéologie cette
croyance au progrès qui va évidemment
quelque peu décliné au 20e siècle
c'est un c'était un élément important de
ces expositions là dessus sur cela c'est
la nécessité d'un développement
économique d'un progrès vous en parlez
dans votre wii alors en fait donc dans
ce scénario fiction donc l'idée c'est
d'avoir cette expo universelle comme
pivot central du récit mais parce le bit
cette hypothèse je propose du coup une
un scénario de développement avec un
volet soft power international pour
commencer pour gagner une fois qu'on a
gagné ensuite il faut développer un
programme d'innovation mais d'innovation
élargie c'est à dire un programme
d'innovations sociétales qui fait que
cette exposition devient un peu le
catalan le catalyseur et un
accompagnement aussi de la mutation de
l'économie contemporaine qui subit quand
même
voilà la transition écologique à
transition digital donc je montre
comment des voiles à l'expo universelle
avec son son challenge de l'innovation
c'est plus la modernité directement ou
la prouesse technologique mais ça reste
néanmoins le terme actuel ce serait le
terme d'innovation qui voilà qui est
aspire à trouver des solutions au grand
challenge contemporain donc l'expo
universelle c'est le déballage de
l'innovation tous azimuts alors de tous
azimuts mais mais aussi elle a été
pensée cette innovation on sait dans
quelle direction va oui bah disons que
je peux je propose comme ça un peu une
stratégie alors évidemment la stratégie
que je propose est assez différente de
celle que l'équipe réel propose que sur
lequel je vois là je trouve il ya
beaucoup d'insuffisances
donc moi je propose voilà un petit peu
des nouveaux mode collaboratif qui
permettent d'accélérer l'innovation
locale et internationale de créer
vraiment en réseau voilà d'accélération
un peu de qui suis né les idées de
l'accélération nisme ce sont des termes
qui est des jargons et puis je montre
aussi tout volet culturel aujourd'hui
l'innovation art une dimension
culturelle très forte et donc je
sculptais dimension culturelle la
métamorphose de l'imaginaire du grand
paris par ce rendez-vous qui après je
vais voir chercher d'autres notre
réflexion sur le futur du web sur le
futur de la religion sur futures du sexe
voilà ça après ça des seuils à ça ça
touche à d'autres strates de la ville
mais en tout cas il me semble que
l'équivalent de 2 ce que la de dix
neuvième siècle aller chercher dans ses
expos universelles de modernité se joue
aujourd'hui par l'idée d'innovation plus
tôt notamment grâce au numérique il
aurait donc c'est cette taille-là
culturelle et non simplement
technologique david ross bah je suis
totalement en phase avec ce qui vient
d'être dit mon coeur je vois qu'on va
avoir une nouvelle ambassadrice pour
notre candidature
elle va plus loin que visiblement vous
restez en face vous avec ce qui est
réalisable alors que lesdits pragmatique
de terrain on essaie de gagner puis
après on verra comment améliorer les
choses mais ce qui est important c'est
cette expo c'est 2025
là nous sommes en 2017 faut voir aussi
la le timing dans lequel on a dû faire
ce dossier d'ailleurs moi je fais ici
toutes les équipes ont été mobilisés
parce que c'est des dossiers assez
conséquent ça a été aussi pour nous
l'occasion de nous bousculer y compris
dans la manière dont on appréhende et le
développement de notre territoire dans
les 15 prochaines années parce que
souvent quand on est mais on est un
petit peu englués dans la gestion au
quotidien
donc on a fait un effort important qui
suis enseignant je sais que c'est pas
suffisant et qu'on peut que progresser
donc imaginez vous n'auriez pas eu cette
candidature a rédigé à envoyer comment
le territoire peut se développer
autrement
l'innovation dont on s'assoit
indépendamment de l'exposition ce qu'on
veut faire sur le cluster en tout cas
moi ce que je pense puisque je suis
vice-président en charge de l'innovation
de la recherche et je suis par ailleurs
scientifique je suis très sensible aux
nouvelles technologies à l'innovation
on essaie de l'expérimenté à l'échelle
du territoire sur la commune dans les
écoles et au niveau de l'agglomération
mais là on a la capacité et
l'opportunité finalement on est un peu
bousculé d'aller plus loin ce qu'on
aurait imaginé dans notre train train
quotidien
très bien c'est au contraire c'est une
opportunité à savoir si je pense qu'il
faut on n'avait pas pensé être candidat
parce que ça c'est un petit peu enchaîné
et on s'est dit mais on est en phase et
on s'aperçoit que finalement il ya
encore des domaines qui doivent être
creusés amplifie je pense que c'est le
volet culturel est complètement absent
je trouve de la candidature
et puis aussi c'est sa façon les gens
avaient ensuite vers ça et vous
l'enlever du domaine culturel vous êtes
un petit peu dur pour l'histoire de
france
ouais mais fort
il me sens que la dimension prospective
culturel justement métamorphose de
locuteurs de la bête de l'imaginaire du
territoire mise en mouvement d'un d'une
créativité tourné vers le futur et il ya
eu tout le volet technologique comme
vous dites et sa clé d'un acteur
important de ce point de vue là mais du
côté vraiment enjeux culturels monde de
la culture il y a un petit peu de
recherches historiques mais il ya un
gros manque dans la de réflexion sur il
ya un élément qui va vouloir finir
puisque si j'arrive à la séduire non non
c'est non mais c'est juste parce qu'un
élément important c'est le projet photo
police et tout ce qui est lié à la photo
puisque la photo on passe de l'histoire
est donc de toutes les technologies qui
ont été faites et du côté artistique aux
enjeux du numérique et de ce qu'on peut
en faire demain et ce à un sujet sur
lequel toutes les cultures peuvent
s'exprimer
donc on a vu un dénominateur commun à
creuser sur le domaine de la photo qui
fait partie des filigranes la
candidature jean charles j'espère
justement sur cet aspect là on entend
parler beaucoup de technologies et c'est
moins culturelle aujourd'hui
l'expression universel également cette
symbolique là parce que c'est quand même
une idée de
du vivre ensemble dans toute l'humanité
un peu réunis sur un même alors
concentré sur ce qu'on vend par culture
l'a fait sur ce plateau soit on parle de
la vie culturelle lag de la création
artistique et c'est bon
traditionnellement l'exposition
universelle était universel justement
parce qu'elle allait au delà de
l'industrie et l'universalité on ne
renvoyait pas à l'idée de l'humanité
entière mais renvoyé aux thématiques
abordées et les expositions était
universel parce qu on y exposait des
produits de l'industrie l'agriculture et
également des beaux-arts donc la culture
était train segment présente dans le
l'exposition universelle au départ après
cette dimension peut-être été dévié
parce que la notion de culture elle-même
a évolué et aujourd'hui voilà la culture
vous avez évoqué le château de
versailles où quelque part là progrès
technologiques aussi c'est un phénomène
culturel et de toute façon ça reste
aussi des événements culturels puisque
les les expositions universelles sont
parmi les les éléments les plus
significatifs de ce qu'on appelle cette
culture de masse cette culture
mondialisée où vous avez des millions de
personnes qui vont participer au même
événement et ça c'est pour l'isoler on
sait que je connais bien c'était c'était
nouveau ça ne m'était jamais arrivé
quand paris accueille voilà en 1950
millions de personnes en quelques mois
c'est voilà on est au coeur de cette
culture de masse qui apparaît à l'époque
encore aujourd'hui je crois qu'il ya cet
aspect là après en effet se pose la
question de la place des des professions
culturelles des institutions culturelles
dans les projets mais vous connaissez le
projet mieux que moi et ramène en parler
il défendre justement tout ça un dernier
mot pour conclure vous aviez inventé la
thématique l'art de bien vivre ensemble
l'art de vivre oms l'art de vivre
ensemble pardon donc c'est vrai qu'il ya
sur cette idée
de communauté de destin de rassembler
tout le monde s'est un petit peu ça
l'idée encore aujourd'hui quand même oui
bah en tout cas si on prend une
exposition universelle dans toute sa
profondeur et je pense que c'est aussi
la france peut marquer une différence en
montrant qu'elle est capable de
réinstaller un niveau de réflexion de
cette ampleur c'est à dire de dire
l'expo universelle c'est vraiment
réinterroger qu'est ce que peut être
l'universalité dans sa dimension
culturelle dans sa dimension cognitive
la science est quand même en un monde
qui est aussi en crise et du coup une
expo universelle peut faire l'objet
voilà une réflexion sur la culture
partagée autour de la planète
et puis finalement qu'est ce que c'est
que la globalisation la france a un peu
pris du retard sur la réflexion sur la
globalisation et le gouvernement passe à
saisir pourquoi aujourd'hui 1 voilà il
me semble que le projet qui est porté
actuellement n'a pas pris la mesure de
cette profondeur et n'a pas les voilà
dans son contenu
ce nouveau de réflexion sur tous ces
points voilà c'est un petit peu sa
colère hydros justement c'est un moyen
de repenser la mobilisation peut-être de
la faire
on a vécu une scène électorale où nous
certains prônent et le repli sur soi
moi je trouve ces quinze cette
candidature elle porte l'ouverture
ouverture aux autres peuvent bien sûr
s'améliorer mais moi j'estime que le
fait de lente et déjà cette candidature
c'est un pas en avant et c'est un signe
très fort et moi je souhaite qu'on gagne
et je souhaite que phil tv 78 voilà en
2025 pour couper le ruban à nos côtés
chercheuse sur un dernier mot là dessus
sur sur cette idée de on est dans un
monde mondialisé mais l'exposition
existe encore pour pour nous pour nous
montrer ses différentes cultures ces
différentes cultures ces différents pays
mais les solutions universelles sont des
éléments de la mondialisation depuis le
début de toute façon donc plus que
jamais aujourd'hui ou on est pour le
coup au coeur de la modélisation et à
cette ambivalence entre finalement on
aime les cultures de chacun on aime les
différences de chacun en fait cette
exposition universelle c'est aussi pour
montrer les différents atouts je crois
qu'à shanghai la france était sur le
luxe etc
enfin des choses assez finalement
classique clichés un peu donc on aime
bien aussi nos différences et en même
temps
on aime bien être tous ensemble dans un
même lieu ce qui nous unit la culture
universelle
ça a pu être plus polémiques je pense
aux représentations des mondes coloniaux
par exemple dans l'exposition
universelle ou là la différence était
mise en scène de façon assez idéologique
et on a évidemment dans les concepts
raciste du 19e siècle donc c'est à
double tranchant mais aujourd'hui je
pense qu'on a un peu évolué heureusement
sur cet aspect là david rose quand
est-ce qu'on saura si vous avez gagné
alors théoriquement c'est avant l'été en
nous avait dit le 21 juin mais comme et
des législatives le 18 juin
pas sûr que le premier conseil des
ministres prennent comme décision 21
juin de choisir le lieu mais de toute
façon la france va déposer son dossier
pour l'automne donc le temps est très
court pour le site qui va être retenu et
décision finale par le bureau
international qui se réunira à paris
donc le vote aura lieu à paris en
octobre ou novembre 2018 très bien merci
à tous les trois d'avoir participé on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine pour une
nouvelle émission merci très bonne fin
de soirée
[Musique]